Not all heroes wear capes.
Some of them wear Pokemon t-shirts and a baseball
cap.
You might think you’ve heard of every superhero
out there, with Marvel and DC dominating the
box office, and the incredible Cactus Man
fighting crime on the mean streets of Edinburgh,
but there is one tiny aspiring hero you’ve
likely never heard of.
In a world filled with danger and evildoers,
one young boy armed with a pure heart and
some telekinetic powers dared to step up and
save the day.
A woman was being abducted at gunpoint when
seven-year-old Cameron spotted the struggle.
He saw the weapon in the man’s hand, the
fear in the woman’s eyes as she looked for
a way out, and he knew that he had to act.
He concentrated with all his might, reaching
out with his mind, and threw the gun out of
the man’s grasp and into some nearby bushes.
The woman ran as fast as she could from there,
but not before catching a glimpse of the child
that had saved her life.
Somehow, she knew that he had been her hero.
Unfortunately for Cameron, but fortunately
for the SCP Foundation, the woman reported
what had happened to a nearby police officer,
who just so happened to be an undercover agent
for the Foundation.
Before Cameron could leave the scene, he was
being approached by a team of armed guards,
and brought to a strange new place filled
with men in lab coats, who kept calling him
“SCP-2241.”
Cameron sat for a very long time in a white
room, wondering whether he was in trouble,
when a new man in a lab coat entered.
He introduced himself as Researcher Valdez
and told Cameron he was going to ask him some
questions.
He asked why Cameron had helped the woman,
instead of running away and getting an adult
to help.
He said, “Superheroes have to help people!
I can move things without touching them and
other people can't so I should use that to
help them!”
He went on to explain that he had practiced
his ability in the woods, and kept it a secret
from everyone.
Valdez asked what sort of things Cameron could
do, and he explained: “I can move stuff
without touching it, but not if it's too far
away or if it's too big.
Only like a cup across a room or a person's
arm or something.
Sometimes it can sorta change as well.”
When prompted, he elaborated, “Sometimes
when I'm moving something it changes to something
I want.
Like one time when I was moving a stone, it
changed to look like a toy I lost.
But it changed back after a while, before
I even got home.”
Cameron became distressed during the interview,
but Valdez promised him that he would be okay
here.
He asked Cameron what his superhero name would
be, and he told him: Cameron the Crusader.
Valdez explained that Cameron would be staying
at the SCP Foundation for a while, so they
could learn more about his powers, and help
him become a better superhero.
Researcher Valdez concluded his interview
with this closing statement: “SCP-2241 appears
to trust me and believes that the Foundation
is attempting to help him as much as possible.
SCP-2241's account is consistent with the
early stages of a humanoid developing a reality-bending
ability.
SCP-2241 may have experienced abuse at the
hands of its parents, leading to early development
of said ability.
In the event that a more developed ability
is required for research, similar emotional
stress can be applied by Foundation staff.”
SCP-2241 is kept in a standard humanoid containment
chamber.
He is given access to television and comic
books, though this access can be cut off as
punishment for bad behavior.
He is fed three balanced meals a day, with
additional treats such as chocolate or ice
cream provided after testing, especially if
the testing goes on for a particularly long
time or is exceptionally stressful.
All personnel that interact with SCP-2241
are to call him by his name, Cameron, when
interacting with him.
Only Cameron’s assigned psychologist and
specifically designated personnel, such as
Valdez are allowed to develop a friendly relationship
with him.
If he becomes attached to an unapproved person,
they are required to discourage this however
they can.
After containment procedures were established,
Valdez and his team set to work putting together
tests that would use Cameron’s emotions
and desire to save people in order to develop
and strengthen his abilities.
For the first test, they deliberately exposed
Cameron to a D-Class that believed him to
be a valuable hostage, one that he could use
to escape from the Foundation.
The D-Class abducted Cameron at knife-point,
but Cameron quickly used his reality-bending
ability to turn the knife into chocolate and
escape.
The knife remained chocolate and did not turn
back to metal, indicating his powers had grown
stronger.
Details of events that followed this test
have been redacted from the official file,
but a note from a member of the Overwatch
Council provides a peek into what might have
happened: “SCP-2241 has stated that it intends
to grow stronger to stop more people from
dying, and this will help both it and us in
this aim.
Killing a man with a teleported bullet was
a stroke of tactical genius from the SCP object.
MTF-Theta-17 will be ready to respond during
all further rounds of testing as a precaution.”
Following a series of tests, each of which
included heightened emotional stakes such
as threatening the lives of innocent bystanders
or treasured items belonging to SCP-2241,
his abilities developed even further.
In one test, a series of armed drones were
made to artificially malfunction, posing an
apparent threat to Foundation personnel around
the boy.
He responded by using his telekinesis to turn
the drones on each other, crashing them into
one another.
When only one drone remained, he teleported
its weaponry to a nearby field, leaving a
harmless shell behind.
In another test, a bomb was detonated near
a member of D-class personnel.
The boy somehow absorbed the energy of the
bomb as it exploded, transforming its kinetic
energy and saving the man’s life.
Another bomb-related test featured a man with
a bomb strapped to him attacking a D-class.
In this test, it was ordered that the bomber
be taken alive.
Cameron responded by teleporting the bomb
vest into an explosion-proof containment chamber,
and knocking the bomber unconscious with a
single punch, though his tiny fist should
not have been capable of delivering such a
strong blow.
In another test, a third bomb was placed in
SCP-2241’s chamber among his personal belongings,
including some stuffed animals and comic books.
He was very upset at this discovery, and teleported
the bomb high up into the sky where it detonated
harmlessly.
He remained upset for a while after, repeating,
“no one can take my things.
It's not fair.
I'm strong.
I'm the crusader.”
Moving on from bombs, the Research Team tasked
the boy with stealing a box from a Foundation
bank vault, which had been modified for extra
security.
He teleported himself into the vault, picked
up the box, and then made a mistake: he tripped
the sensors inside.
However, he somehow slowed the sensors down
and was able to teleport himself back out
of the vault before the alarm could sound.
This was the first task given to Cameron that
could be perceived as morally grey, or even
villainous, but he performed it without question,
and this was recorded as a notable development.
Next, a surprise long-range attack was performed
on the Foundation Site by a Foundation-owned
robotic mortar. 2241 became angry, catching
the bomb and throwing it toward the launcher
at a speed that appeared to be approximately
1.4 times the speed of sound.
It was noted that his abilities were less
focused, and his demeanor more violent, when
he was angry.
He turned to an observing researcher and said,
“I hate them.
I’m a Foundation Avenger and I hate the
bad guys and I’m gonna fight them all.”
For the final test in this series, two D-Classes,
who were described to 2411 as civilians, were
held at gunpoint in rooms with bulletproof
glass windows.
He was told that the guns could not be affected
by his powers, the hostages needed physical
contact to be teleported to safety, and he
needed to rescue them both before they were
killed.
Shocking the research team, he split into
two versions of himself, each teleporting
a hostage to safety before returning to the
crime scene to subdue the “bad guys.”
He reported feeling a bit sick afterwards,
but had no other adverse effects from splitting
himself into two people.
By the time this series of tests was completed,
he was able to teleport objects as well as
his own body, duplicate himself, see a few
seconds into the future, and move or transform
objects within a distance of twelve meters.
He was excited about these improvements, referring
to them as “leveling up.”
Following these tests, Valdez planned to pause
the psychiatric treatment of SCP-2241 in favor
of a more hands-on approach.
The plan was to begin neurological testing
using a surgically implanted chip that would
monitor the boy’s brain activity during
combat.
The Ethics Committee caught wind of this and
immediately intervened.
They temporarily revoked Valdez’s security
clearance and placed him under investigation.
They submitted an official report on this
decision, which read: “Implanting a monitoring
chip into a child this young can not be done
without significant developmental damage in
later years.
This will cause catastrophic problems for
both the child and long term containment,
given his well developed capabilities.
Additionally, deploying a child in combat,
even under testing conditions, violates all
moral norms.
Personnel involved in sweeping the previous
rapid-fire tests under the rug are under review.”
The testing and research surrounding SCP-2241
did not only draw the attention of the Ethics
Committee, but it also caused discord within
the Overwatch Council itself.
Following the Ethics Committee intervention,
O5-3 ordered that the testing be resumed,
writing: “These tests are more important
than one SCP, regardless of whether it looks
like a child.
Long-term containment and observation is no
longer a priority, given the utility of data
we have collected via intensive testing in
the short term.
The risk of the SCP breaching containment
is minimal, given its loyalty.
We now know which parts of the brain deal
with certain anomalous abilities.
With more detail, we can see how.
We may even learn how to induce these abilities
- and we will definitely learn how to neutralize
them.”
Two other members of the Council were horrified
by this statement, believing that it went
against decency and morality in a way that
could not be justified.
O5-4 submitted a statement: “This is too
far.
We can not let this stand as precedent.
This is but one step removed from child soldiers
and even less removed from militarizing an
SCP-level object.”
An emergency Council meeting was called to
address this internal disagreement, and the
majority voted in favor of reinstating testing,
and exonerating Valdez of all ethics violations.
“I believe the results will justify both
the risks and the means.
We are closer than ever to understanding the
mechanism by which human brains interact with
extranormal phenomena.
The emotional and eventual neurological damage
to SCP-2241 is… unfortunate but it is also
necessary for the advancement of our understanding.
In addition, due to the new modification of
the monitoring hardware, 2241 can be neutralized
quickly should it become a threat at any time
after the surgery.”
And so, the protests of the Ethics Committee
were ignored, the concerned members of the
Overwatch Council overruled, and Valdez was
allowed to resume his plan for testing and
preparing to craft a superpowered child into
a weapon.
And all the while, a little boy named Cameron
remained the test subject of the SCP Foundation,
still dreaming of the day when he might have
a chance to save the world.
Now go check out “SCP-953 - Polymorphic
Humanoid” and “SCP-213 - Anti-Matter Parasite”
for more superpowered humanoid anomalies!